The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So if we
switch to today's lecture
notes, we're going to
talk today about applying
some of the chemistry knowledge,
with clicker questions
and a clicker
championship, to the issue
of using CO2 to make biofuels.
So first I just want
to briefly review
the course objectives, what I
was hoping people would get out
of this course.
So I was hoping that you
would know enough chemistry,
have enough basic
chemistry knowledge
to do a UROP in the
Chemistry Department
without taking any other
chemistry classes; that in UROP
positions in other departments
you would be using chemistry
in your research; that you could
also appreciate how chemistry
is used to solve real world
problems like we're talking
about today, make
informed decisions
about your own health,
the health of your family,
environmental issues,
energy issues, a lot
of political decisions
that are going on-- there's
a lot of science actually
in the news these days;
and hopefully, make
the world a better
place by applying chemical
principles to problems
in science and engineering.
So those are my goals.
And then if we just kind
of look at the material
that we've covered.
The first half of
the course, which
will be Exam One,
Exam Two material--
talked about the
basic properties
of matter, atomic theory,
periodic table, bonding
structures of molecules.
And then thermodynamics
kind of transitioned us
from thinking about
basic properties
to thinking more
about reactivity
and how that material
that we learned
about in the first half,
how those elements could
come together and react
to form molecules.
And to think about
how things react,
we usually think
about thermodynamics.
We need to think about chemical
equilibrium, acid base,
oxidation, and sometimes,
transition metals,
because they are-- that middle
part of the periodic table
can do amazing chemistry-- and
also kinetics and solubility.
So all of these things are
about how material reacts.
So we can't review everything.
But I thought we would stick
with this sort of carbon
dioxide biofuels theme.
And see how some of the things
we've learned in this course
would help us
understand how we could
approach this problem,
how people are
trying to solve this problem.
So what is the problem again?
And Jingnan brought this
up, CO2 is a waste product
of combustion of fossil fuels.
We want to remove it
from our environment.
It's a greenhouse gas.
It's also leading to the
acidification of the oceans.
This is not a molecule
we want around
in the kind of quantities
that it is around.
And I am personally very
concerned about climate change.
And after those of you who
are freshman experience
this winter, I think you
will also be very concerned
about climate change.
So this is a problem.
What is the approach?
Well, the idea, I
think, is really great--
that you can take CO2 and
not just get rid of it,
but convert it into
something we want,
which is alternative
fuels, like biofuels.
So I think this is a
really great thing.
So there are a few ways
that one could do it.
You could think about designing
small molecule catalysts
to do this.
This is one thing
people are doing.
But there's really
been a lot of energy
on looking at how
nature does things.
So a lot of people are
interested in nature,
thinking about biological
pathways that already do this.
They already remove CO2 from
our environment and fix it.
Form carbon carbon
bonds and make it
into multicarbon chains that
can be used as biofuels.
So but before we do any of
this, before we can go and think
about any of these
solutions, we need
to understand the basic
properties of CO2,
it's reactivity, and more
about these pathways.
So let's talk about
carbon dioxide,
and let's think about how carbon
and oxygen are bonded together.
And we can use Lewis
structures to predict
what the Lewis structure
of this should be,
what the bonding will be.
So let's go ahead with our
first, our clicker question,
and predict which
of these, and we
have a little bit of
the periodic table,
is the correct Lewis
structure for CO2.
OK.
10 more seconds.
All right.
So we're going to
go through and just
look at what's wrong with
some of these structures
as a review.
But first, can someone tell
me for a t-shirt, what is
the equation for formal charge?
And Alaina will
bring you the mic.
AUDIENCE: One half
the number of bonds
that are going on plus the
number of loan pair electrons.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Right.
So I think we're missing one
thing-- so formal charge,
or maybe I didn't hear it.
We have the number of valence
electrons that we have,
which for carbon was what?
Four.
So for carbon was four, and
for oxygen is six, right.
So minus the number of lone pair
and then half of the bonding
electrons.
So this is how we're
going to do this.
The first structure has
zero formal charges.
It's good.
And that is, in fact,
the correct structure.
The second structure
here, if we do it out
we have oxygen in the middle
and we have carbon on the end.
And here we should have a
formal charge of minus 2
on that carbon and plus
2 on the middle oxygen.
So it's not good, because it
has charges, which is not good.
But it's also not good
because the negative charge
should be on what type of atom?
A more electronegative,
so that's not true here.
So that structure is not good
for a variety of reasons.
OK, so if we look at
the next structure,
we have six valence electrons
around one of the oxygens.
We have two bonds to
carbon and two lone pairs.
And we have-- oh,
actually we have the six
around the other one as well.
So first off, if
you counted, there's
more valence electrons
used here than you had.
So that's not good.
And if you look at the
charges, it's minus 1, minus 2,
and minus 1.
So that's a lot of
charge, but also,
what else is wrong with that?
It should add up to
0, which it does not.
And it doesn't add
up to 0, because I
put extra valence electrons
in there that do not exist.
So this structure is bad
for a lot of reasons.
Also the higher
negative charge is not
on the most
electronegative atom.
So this has many
things wrong with it.
So then if we looked
at number four--
so we have an oxygen
with six around it,
a carbon that has
two lone pairs double
bonded to an oxygen
with two lone pairs.
And this has minus
1 and also minus 1.
So again charges don't add up.
It has the wrong number
of valence electrons.
So that's bad.
And then the last one-- we have
an oxygen with six lone pair
electrons, a carbon with three
bonds, no lone pair electrons,
and an oxygen with
two double bonds,
two loan pair electrons,
minus 1, plus 1.
So this is not zero like
that one is up there.
But also something
else is wrong.
What else is wrong
with that structure?
What's wrong with the carbon?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't add up to 8.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Right,
so it has an complete octet.
And so sometimes you can
have an incomplete octet.
Does anybody remember what
two elements we mentioned
are happy with an
incomplete octet?
AUDIENCE: Boron.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Boron
and aluminum, right.
And then some of them are
happy with an expanded
octet, but to be
expanded you have
to have an n number of what?
Three or above.
So carbon does not want
to have a deficient octet
or an expanded octet.
So many of these other ones
had a lot of things wrong.
And so this is something that
could be useful to review.
And again, Lewis structure
is one thing that people go,
oh, yeah, I know how to do it.
But it's good to review the
rules right before an exam.
OK, so here with our
correct Lewis structure.
And that Lewis
structure stood well.
That's a good structure.
OK, so now that we know
the Lewis structure,
we can think about the
geometry of the molecule, what
its angles are, what
it looks like in 3D.
And we can use our friend, the
Valence Shell Electron Pair
Repulsion theory and
Valence Bond Theory
to predict things
about this structure.
So why don't you tell me which
ones of these are correct?
[CLASSROOM CHATTER]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: All right.
10 more seconds.
[CLASSROOM CHATTER]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: All right?
OK, so let's take
a look at that.
So valence shell electron
pair repulsion theory--
the AX, no AXE nomenclature.
So X is the number of atoms
bonded, and there are two here.
So it's AX2.
If there had been lone
pairs, which they're not
on the carbon, we
would have added an E
to indicate the lone pair.
And AX2 molecules are linear.
So here we have our
carbon monoxide.
It just has a single bond.
This model kit doesn't
have double bonds,
but we have a linear
molecule there.
And again valence shell
theory is really just
about minimizing the
repulsion between things.
So the atoms, and
especially those lone pairs
that really take
up a lot of room,
try to position themselves
around the central atom
so it's the least repulsive.
So in valence bond theory leads
to the idea of hybrid orbitals.
This idea that the
valence electrons
are available for bonding.
And that you're not really
just having s orbitals
and p orbitals
separate, you're really
forming these hybrid
orbitals, which
tell you about the geometry
around individual atoms.
So the number of
hybrid orbitals is
the number of bonded atoms
and the number of lone pairs.
So carbon has two bonded atoms.
So it's sp, and n
equals 2, so it's 2sp.
And oxygen has one atom
and two lone pairs.
Again the number of bonds
doesn't matter here.
So it has one plus two or
three, so its sp2 and again
n equals 2.
So 2sp2.
And then we can also have
questions about the geometries,
what are the angles
for the different types
of hybridization?
So this really gets at what
the geometry at every atom
is like, whereas
the vesper is really
thinking about the overall
shape of the molecule
around the central
atom and not so much
about the individual atoms.
All right, and
remember that if we
have a singly-bonded terminal
atom, it's not hybridized.
But this is not singly-bonded.
OK, so now we can
also ask what is
the polarity of this
molecule, and that's
one more clicker question.
All right 10 more seconds.
All right.
So if the polar bear
t-shirt had won,
it would have given it away.
But it didn't matter,
you still remembered.
So, yeah, it does
have polar bonds.
Electronegativity
difference greater than 0.4
does make it a polar
bond, but because it is
linear there's no net dipole.
So the polar bond-- this
cancels each other out
with this linear geometry.
Great.
So non-polar molecule, even
though it has polar bonds.
So it's not just
about the property
of the bonds that's important.
It's also about the overall
shape of the molecule.
OK, so we have looked at some
of the basic properties of CO2
now, which is the top part.
And now let's move in to think
about the reactivity of the CO2
molecule.
So when we're thinking about
reactivity we want to say
is CO2 a stable or
an unstable molecule
compared to its elements?
And this is not a
clicker question.
So you can just tell me.
To answer this question
about stability of a molecule
compared to its
elements, what is
the thing I want to know about?
Yeah, I want to know about
delta G. In particular, I
want to know about the delta G
of formation of this molecule.
But if you said delta G,
that would be very good.
So here the delta G of formation
of CO2 is a negative number.
It's a fairly big
negative number
minus 394 kilojoules per mol.
So is CO2 stable or unstable?
And you can just yell this out?
It's stable, right.
So the way we're thinking about
this is with a delta G that's
negative, it's spontaneous
in the forward direction,
which means it's not spontaneous
in the reverse direction.
So CO2 decomposing into its
elements is not spontaneous.
So that makes it
a stable molecule.
All right, so let's kind of
put all these things together
about CO2 now.
So according to the Lewis
structure, it has double bonds.
And usually a double bond
means that it's harder
to disassociate a big
bond dissociation energy.
And you don't need
to know these,
but in case you're
interested, when
you have carbon double
bonded to oxygen,
you have a bond dissociation
energy of about 805 kilojoules
per mol.
And it depends a little on
the molecule in question,
but a single bond
is more like 358.
And so double bond, it's
hard to disassociate that.
And it's also linear,
non-polar, and stable.
All right.
So we want to take CO2 and
turn it into other stuff.
We want to make biofuels and
solve the energy problem.
But this is a non-polar
molecule, and it's very stable.
It has strong bonds.
This is a hard challenge.
And if it were an
easy challenge,
we would have figured this out.
But this is not
an easy challenge.
It's a hard challenge,
which is why
it is a big area of
research right now.
So fixing CO2, i.e., putting
these 1 carbon units together
to make these long
chain carbons like you
saw in Jingnan's video, when she
talked about these multichain
carbons being used as biofuels.
This is hard.
All right, so when
things are hard,
first thing that scientists
often like to do is say,
can someone solve this
problem and can we
steal an idea from them?
Honestly, that's what we do.
But it's OK when the people
we want to steal from
are not really people,
but Mother Nature.
And so we look to
Mother Nature and we
look to some of the most
intelligent life forms I know,
which are microbes and bacteria.
Oh man, can they do amazing
chemistry that we cannot do.
They are fantastic chemists,
these little microbes.
So one approach is to look
at a microbe that does
a process called acetogenesis.
And that is one of the six
known pathways of CO2 fixation.
So acetogenesis makes acetate,
or what's known as Acetyl-CoA.
That's Coenzyme A.
And this is considered
the most ancient pathway
of carbon fixation
before origins
of life kind of times,
high CO2 environment,
that maybe this was one of
the first reactions that sort
of generated metabolic fuel.
And so here you have two
molecules of CO2, one in blue,
one in red, that are both
converted to other carbons
units that are then
combined with Coenzyme A
to make Acetyl-CoA, which then
can go on to make biofuels.
So this is what we
want to understand,
and we want to use this and
turn our CO2 into biofuels.
So but before we
do this again, we
must understand how it works.
And we can ask the
following questions.
Are there redox
reactions involved?
Yes, there are.
Is there acid-base catalysis?
Why, yes, of course, there is.
Are there transition
metals involved?
Is this hard chemistry?
Yes, therefore pretty
much guaranteed they'll
be transition metals involved.
Are there challenging
rate-limiting steps?
Oh, there's always, something's
always rate-limiting,
absolutely.
And what about the
chemical equilibrium?
What about our [INAUDIBLE]?
All right, so let's
review the second half
material thinking about the
process of acetogenesis.
First, oxidation
reduction-- so you
can tell me with a
clicker question what
is happening to CO2?
And what's happening
to blue CO2,
and what's happening to red CO2?
Are they being
reduced or oxidized?
All right.
10 more seconds.
Great.
OK, so let's take
a look at that.
So that is right,
the top reaction.
So both of these are plus 4.
It's the same molecule.
And so in one case
you're going to minus 2.
So it's a 6 electron process.
And in the other,
you're going to plus 2.
But both of them
are being reduced.
And so that is what's happening
in a lot of these carbon
fixation pathways.
You're reducing carbon
dioxide and making it
into hydrocarbons, which
can be used for biofuel.
And the precursor here is the
reduced form of this 2 carbon
molecule, this Acetyl-CoA.
All right, so it's
being reduced.
Now this is a fairly
large reduction.
Six electrons is a lot.
Most of the reagents in nature
that do reduction chemistry
do one or two
electron processes.
So six is a lot.
And in fact, it requires
five different enzymes
to do this six
electron reduction.
So it's not just
one enzyme, it's
multiple enzymes
that need to do this.
So this raises a question then.
How are these carbon units, if
you take one, you reduce it.
Then you reduce it again and
remove it to another enzyme,
reduce it again and remove
it to another enzyme,
and reduce it again, move
it to another enzyme.
How does that happen?
How do the enzymes kind
of pass things along?
And I think about this as
a problem like kindergarten
soccer.
So we have a bunch of enzymes.
And we have a bunch
of one carbon units.
But the one carbon units do
not get passed from enzyme
to enzyme in an
organized fashion.
And in fact,
sometimes the enzymes
don't really have control
of those 1 carbon units.
They can't grab it
with their hands.
That's not allowed.
And we know enzymes do
not have hands as such.
So how do the enzymes grab
onto these one carbon units
and how does an enzyme bring
it from one enzyme to the next.
And why-- you know it
takes energy to reduce CO2.
So you don't want to just
reduce it and kind of pass it
along, and then who knows
what happens to that reduced
molecule.
You want to go to the next
enzyme and the next enzyme
and the next enzyme.
You want to make
your Acetyl-CoA.
So how does nature do it?
It has a solution to the
kindergarten soccer problem,
and its solution is a
B vitamin folic acid,
also known as folate.
And we talked about this before.
This is why some
people might want
to drink Norwegian beer,
lots of folic acid in it,
or orange juice, or eat
leafy green vegetables.
So here's folic acid
in its large form.
In your notes, it just has
an R. This entire thing
is abbreviated as R. And
what these enzymes do is
they grab onto R, to that arm.
And they hold onto it and they
bind their one carbon unit over
here.
And then one enzyme
does a reduction.
And then it releases it,
attached to folic acid.
The next enzyme grabs onto the
folate acid by the R group,
reduces it again, lets go of it.
The next enzyme grabs onto
the folic acid by the R,
reduces it again and this works.
This is a great thing.
You have something small.
You don't want it just
fre floating in the cell,
especially if it's not
really all that soluble.
So you use something
else to hold onto it.
You use a vitamin to hold
onto it this is great.
But there's a problem.
Well, first let's say, it
holds onto it really well.
You can pass it really well.
This is great.
But then when you
get to the end,
you're holding onto
it really tight.
You get to the end-- how
do you get the methyl
group off the folic acid?
Great vehicle, but
you need a final step.
You need to remove
it when you're done.
So when the enzymes
are done, how
is this methyl group,
CH3 group removed?
And now we need to think
about acid-base chemistry.
So it turns out that
the deprotonated form
of folic acid, very hard
to remove the methyl group.
Whereas the protonated
form of folic acid here,
with the proton H in
red, it's much easier
to remove the methyl group.
So if the pKa of folic acid
is 4.8, how much of folic acid
will be deprotonated compared to
protonated at physiological pH?
All right.
10 more seconds.
Yeah.
So sometimes these
things move around.
The fonts change.
So more will be deprotonated.
I see that people
are paying attention.
And we can look at
exactly how much more.
So if we're going to look
at exactly how much more,
what equation do I
want to haul out?
And Henderson-Hasselbalch.
I should have a little
approximate there,
but still, there it is.
So we have pH of 7.4.
pKa of 4.8.
And if we solve this, we have
much more that is deprotonated.
And again, the deprotonated
form is nonreactive.
So this is true off the
enzyme, just a folic acid.
It is not in a state that's
going to react very well.
You're not going to get that
methyl group off very easily.
Most of it will be
deprotonated and nonreactive.
That's fine if you're
just transporting it,
and that's great.
Your body does this.
You have methyl tetrahydrofolate
in your blood right now.
And you have an enzyme that
takes off the methyl group.
And you need an
enzyme to catalyze it,
because it needs to be
a catalyzed reaction.
It's not going to go on its own.
So again, just to remember
our little pretty pictures.
When the pH equals the pKa,
you have equal number of moles
of protonated and deprotonated.
At pH's below the pKa,
it's more protonated.
And a pH's above the pKa,
it's more deprotonated.
OK, so again we have
the problem here
that the removal of this
methyl group is challenging,
this is in fact a very
challenging reaction
both for humans and microbes.
And so the solution, of course,
transition metal and an enzyme.
So you need both the
transition metal, Vitamin B-12,
bound to an enzyme to be
able to do this really
challenging chemistry.
So this is one of the hard
steps in this pathway.
So Vitamin B-12 we have
talked about before.
It's an example of a naturally
occurring metal chelate.
You have cobalt in the middle
of this core and ring system.
And you have cobalt in
the plus 1 oxidation
state is very reactive and it's
capable of removing that methyl
group from the folic acid and
transferring it to itself,
forming a methyl
cobalt 3 species.
And here's the little
methyl group on top.
So we know about
transition metals as well,
and we can figure
out the d-count.
So we can look at
the periodic table.
And remember what about cobalt?
What do we need
to know from this?
And so our d-count
would be what then?
You can just yell it out ,
it's not a clicker question.
So it was group 9?
So we have 9 minus 1, or 8 d8.
And over here we have
9 minus 3 equals 8?
No, d6-- yes, there's a typo.
d6 is right, the other math
is incorrect, d6 system.
OK, I was doing this
at 3:00 in the morning.
OK, geometry around
the central metal.
And it's a little
hard to see from this,
so I'm going to help you out.
So here there are no
upper or lower ligands
in the code one state.
So you just have
the ring system.
So what is this geometry?
Yeah, so we have
square planar geometry.
And then in the
code three state,
you have a methyl group above.
And now you're also interacting
with this lower ligand.
So now our geometry is what?
And what do we call
this core and ring that
has four points of attachment?
Tetradentate.
Right?
Dent from teeth like claws
grabbing onto your metal.
OK so before we do our
last chemical equilibrium,
do we have a winner?
We have a winner.
We do not need a tie breaker.
OK, we'll announce
that at the end.
And if you're the
winning recitation,
please come down to
collect your t-shirts.
OK so very briefly then,
chemical equilibrium.
So this B-12 enzyme which
catalyzes the reaction,
it not only uses this
transition metal, but it also
hydrogen bonds to the folic
acid and lowers that transition
state energy.
And so here is the enzyme.
And this enzyme exists in
multiple confirmations.
So we can think about
chemical equilibrium
in terms of enzyme structure.
Chemical equilibrium applies
to so many processes, not just
a plus b equals c plus d.
So here we have our B-12
enzyme, the B-12 is bound here.
And this is the
state, it's closed.
B-12 is highly reactive, so
it needs to be protected.
When you bind the enzyme
that binds the folic acid,
it opens a little.
When you bind the folic
acid, it opens a lot
and it's able to do the
methyl transfer reaction.
Then it needs to close up again
to protect the methyl group.
And then it needs to go
on to transfer that methyl
group to the enzyme
that makes Acetyl-CoA.
So you have all of
these equilibrium, which
are shifted by the
binding of various things,
the binding of the other enzymes
or the binding of substrates.
So the important point is
that enzymes are dynamic.
Chemistry is dynamic.
This is not about just
chemistry in the solid state.
Chemistry in solution is cool!
And chemistry in solution
can save the planet.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So
if you appreciate this,
this is how we're going to make
biofuels and save the planet.
All right.
We have what I would consider
as a bit of an upset.
The winner of the 2014
t-shirt clicker competition
is Jay's Recitation.
In second place, we have Lisa's
recitation in second place.
And in third place, which
will also have a prize,
we have Odin's Recitation.
So good luck on the final.
It's been a pleasure.